wer wäre denn der bessere
Kanzlerkandidat Friedrich Merz oder
Daniel Günther dieser von ihnen so
geschätzte Ministerpräsident also für
mich ist es steht das außer Frage das
wird auch Herr März verstehen dass ich
Daniel Günther für den besseren halten
würde wirklich naja ich wie gesagt deine
Günther schätze ich sehr dass es mein
Minister sehr also
sie haben nicht gefragt ob Herr März
auch geeignet wäre also von daher aber
werde geeignet das sollte doch mal ein
paar andere Fragen ich soll ja nicht
alleine hier reden aber sie haben noch
eine Meinung dazu ja ich meine sie sind
doch in der CDU Entschuldigung ja
natürlich ich Chef kann das doch oder
nicht also ich würde noch einmal
festhalten ich halte Herr märz für ein
sehr fähigen Politiker und ich bin froh
dass er CDU ist nein also ein
selbstverständlich aber noch mal ich
glaube nicht dass wenn sie Sympathie mit
jemandem haben dass sie sagen würden
100% alles was dieser Mensch sagt nein
kein Mensch der so sagen würde
[Musik]